thomas asks what forms of media do you
consume and are there any particular
people you listen to Thomas how are you
thank you for the opening question on
episode 18 a little bit of better mood
for me than 17 uh I consume a lot of
Twitter predominantly a little bit of
Facebook newsfeed a little bit of
espn.com I actually consume a shockingly
low percentage of media and as it comes
to following people who do I listen to
again I really don't really pay
attention to a whole lot of taste makers
or notable figures I'm very within I'm
very selfishly stuck in my cocoon but
this is we're going to throw you for a
curveball and I do think it's a
differentiator I spend an obnoxious
heavy amount of time listening to my
community last night after lots of
meetings right before bed instead of
consuming stuff as the normal
marketplace does i was reading the
comments that a lot of you left for me
in yesterday's episode it is more
interesting to me to understand what my
the people that i'm lucky enough to give
me their attention what they're looking
for from me a little bit about their
life I know that chef Lizette is moving
to New York I'm consuming my community
which i think is me repaying what you're
paying me with which is your attention
I'm giving you back my attention and so
I haven't anchored myself maybe at a
pride or bravado or ego to other
tastemakers or leaders I don't do that
at all it keeps me fresh in some way it
continues to allow me to be in my lingo
and I don't really want to be affected
I'm very in my zone so my consumption is
quite low I read tech mean Jason
Hirschhorn email for like what's in the
news but I'm not consuming much and I'm
not following much except for you
Oh